danil en maître de conférence et membres
des économistes atterrés bonjour merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france alors on
l'a vu c'est un ouf de soulagement pour
les anglais et qui qualifie même de
cadeaux de noël c'est cet accord qu'est
ce qui vous inspire à vous à cet accord
pose briques site du jeu c'est la fin
d'un long feuilleton dont on nous a pas
mal comment dire buriné les oreilles si
je puis me permettre l'expression c'est
la fin d'un long feuilleton et d'une
longue tragédie
les européens étaient bien décidés à
faire payer cher aux anglais sett cette
sortie qui a été je le rappelle choisi
par référendum
maintenant on est arrivés à un accord
alors que on agitait le spectre d'un
odile un accord qui est très largement
favorable aux anglais sur bien des
aspects et en particulier sur des
aspects comme la pêche ou alors le libre
échange les anglais vont pouvoir
continuer d'exporter leurs produits et
au sein de l'union européenne
comme si de rien n'était alors qu'on a
mis entre parenthèses des choses qui
auraient pu y figurer comme par exemple
d accord pour envoyer des étudiants les
fameuses accords erasmus qui sont
totalement absents de ce de cet accord
qui a finalement été obtenu hier alors
vous l'avez dire le royaume il semble en
tout cas a sorti la grande gagnante de
ces négociations est ce que ce deal est
viable dans la durée écoutez je ligneurs
ça me fait un peu sourire de voir une
europe qui est quand même d'un chant
choeurs de la diminution des droits
sociaux de ces dernières années
fixé comme condition royaume uni des
conditions de respect des droits
environnementaux sociaux et ses terrains
c'est vrai que le royaume uni a pas mal
rogner sur ses droits mais les autres
pays européens aussi ces dernières
années donc je ne sais pas si ça va être
peut respecter dans la durée ça va être
très dur en tout cas pour les pêcheurs
français mais on verra bien on verra
bien effectivement les grands vainqueurs
de cet accord ce sont les britanniques
qui en agitant le spectre d'un odile ont
obtenu à peu près tout ce qu'il
demandait depuis le départ on l'a évoqué
également l'avenir des pêcheurs français
et européen est fortement compromis les
pertes seront elles considérable pour
ces derniers alors il faut voir à terme
à court terme qui sont censés reverser
25 % en numéraire monétaire de ce qu'ils
auront pêché au britannique
donc il faut voir combien ça va
représenter monétairement il faut voir
aussi si le rhodium unis il va pas
revenir sur ces 1 5%
c'est quand même assez important et ça
représente des pertes important pour ces
pêcheurs et un petit caillou dans la
chaussure qui s'appelle les causes qui a
appelé de nouveau à un référendum est
les écossais qui ont voté non au bric
site
est-ce que ce deal peut-il au contraire
divisé les britanniques au royaume uni
je crois pas que c'est ce deal qui va
diviser les les britanniques les
écossais demande leur indépendance
depuis longtemps et ils veulent surtout
obtenir une souveraineté en matière de
politique budgétaire et en matière de
politique monétaire
donc c'est une revendication de prendre
leur destin en main du point de vue des
politiques économiques
c'est une revendication ancienne elle ne
date pas de ce référendum sur le break
site ou non les écossais n'ont pas voté
nombre excite parce qu'ils sont
particulièrement attachés à une certaine
vision de l'europe ils ont voté non
bressy parce que majoritairement les
aimerait disposer de leur indépendance
quitte à rejoindre
européenne par la suite c'est ce qu'ils
envisagent en tout cas et n'a en tous
cas qui sort grandi de ces négociations
c'est évidemment un boris johnson à qui
a gagné son pari et qui s'assure
peut-être un avenir plus serein en tout
cas dans l'avenir politique et
britanniques au bon c'est pas vraiment
une surprise boris johnson est sorti
très renforcé des dernières élections
il a amorcé un virage du parti
conservateur qui est en train de rompre
complètement avec la doctrine
thatchérienne libéral et cetera il faut
rappeler que le royaume uni le pays ans
dans l'union européenne qui a le plus
augmenté le salaire minimum depuis
monsieur johnson est au pouvoir et donc
là effectivement il va être renforcée
par ce deal mais je ne pense pas que ce
johnson aurait été comment dire qu'il
aurait été baignée de se retrouver face
à un audi lille aurait rencontré des
problèmes commerciaux et économiques et
des bancs effective ans leur force
d'avoir cet accord de libre échange mais
il était bien fort avant cet accord dont
la dernière à question rapidement si on
s'attache à ce qui est ce qui s'est
passé durant tous ces mois pourra
négocier durement le break site est ce
que ça peut inspirer d'autres pays de
l'union européenne même si ça a été
compliqué pour le royaume-uni finalement
je l'ignorent mais en tout cas il est
clair que l'union européenne apporte une
maman les britanniques ont choisi par
référendum de sortir
et l'union européenne a tout fait pour
montrer que sortir de l'union européenne
était un processus difficile compliqué
et éviter que d'autres ne s'inspire de
cet exemple britannique donc l'union
européenne a clairement dit qu'il était
extrêmement compliqué de sortir
maintenant le les anglais ont montré
qu'on peut sortir et gagné au passage je
ne suis pas sûr qu'il soit forcément une
bonne chose du point de vue économique
et social pour tout le monde de ce qui
s'est passé mais en tout cas l'exemple
anglais montre qu'on peut sortir de
l'union européenne mais pour choisir son
propre avenir
indépendamment de l'union européenne
finalement les anglais ont toujours eu
un pied à l'intérieur et un pied à
l'extérieur le général de gaulle avait
sans doute raison de dire que les
anglais n'avaient rien à faire dans
l'union européenne cee depuis des années
qu'ils s'acharnent à faire en sorte que
le budget européen soit le plus faible
possible
chaque fois on a un premier ministre
britannique qui dit qu'il a négocié un
budget plus faible maintenant l'union
européenne perd son prétexte habituel
pour ne pas voter un budget fédéral plus
conséquent il faut rappeler que le
budget fédéral européen extrêmement
faibles il est de l'ordre de 1% du pib
donc maintenant elle perdu l'une de ses
principales des excuses et on va voir
comment les choses vont évoluer
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
maître de conférence et membres des
économistes atterrés